[Music]
just before we went i said harris don't
you disappear on me and what did you do
you cheeky american you
you
i am
hello good afternoon good morning good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to scitrek your sci-fi
tv movie channel with
harris over here look at you little
fella look at him oh he's so cute and
stormy bear on the end
royal pain in my ass
i i caught some covid last week stormy
and i think i've quoted off you
so cozy congratulations
you can now get through youtube channels
so you've all got it that's how it's
spread so good we're all screwed
oh yes
and but anyway guys how are you how you
doing
i'm doing well i finally tested negative
yes i got a negative test i'm so happy
you sound a lot better after a minute
it's a little snotty but in a lot of
that
oh you beautiful human being this is how
you introduce that you came on earlier
and i didn't even get the words you
write stormy out and you just
anyway right so this week we're going to
do something a little bit different a
lot of people around the world think
that amazon with their rings of power
have completely wasted a billion dollars
so we thought we'd show them how it was
done properly and we will take one
billion of amazon's dollars
and we will pitch projects that we would
love to make and guys get in the
comments
as we're pitching ideas if you've got
any ideas yourself hi shelley hi ellie
um if you've got any ideas yourself you
know if you throw them over we'll we'll
we'll chuck them in
um
so we'll we'll just pack on and then
what we're going to do at the end is
we'll go through what projects we think
we'll do a bit of math and we'll figure
out what projects we
on side trek are going to tell amazon to
maybe make
which i don't think they'll listen but
anyway
so
we'll just go straight into it
iris do you wanna go first what's your
first project you'd like to pitch to the
group to see what yeah
do it
do we want to real quick i don't want to
derail or anything but do we want to go
over what we've seen in the past week
yes yes yes i have okay let's do that
then just get one
go on then what have you done
i'm gonna
lose my mind
all right well i did watch that watch
the new game of thrones of course
finished what we do in the shadows of
season four i believe is the one they've
just been airing which was fantastic sad
as hell but it was great uh that's some
good fantasy stuff that's just straight
comedy at the same time it's it's
fantastic um
but we're on side tracks so we should be
talking about sci-fi stuff so rick and
morty is back on our screens and that
was fantastic i've never watched an
episode of rick and morty ever
some of my students swear i'm rick
sanchez
don't know what you're talking about
never watched it
you will you'd enjoy it it's it's it's
kind of crass at times but it's
fantastic it is kind of crass it's very
impressive
i'm kind of crass so to be honest
american custom british is a bit
different
it's not the boys crass no but it is
crass yes okay
i have seen little nippets and i think
it looks like something i didn't use i
think it's just because it's not on a
network i watch so i've never seen
adverts for i think it's on fox over
here and i just don't watch fox so i've
never watched it
yeah thankfully i have youtube tv so
that's the only place i really watch it
because i feel like you have to wait
almost for a whole season to be able to
watch it on the streaming service most
of the time
there you go
how about you stormy what you've been
watching
well i i did a little bit of penny worth
catching up with the with the penny war
series which i think is like
of course house of dragon um i'm on
season three of uh stargate atlantis
trying to wha
i'm binging all of stargate all of it so
i still have
about half of uh atlantis to go then i
start on sgu
rings of power of course i thought the
last episode came out
on friday was really good
you know you see you know it's it's it's
less world building more
uh character development
and um
you know the the one thing that was
really i thought emotional was the
harford's
telling of
the people who got left behind people
that are no longer with them kind of
their
funerary uh ritual it was god it was
[ __ ] just heart-wrenching i thought
and you know but let's come down to the
worst piece of [ __ ] i saw now i i took
you guys advice
not to go pay
for thor
eleventh
smart waited for it to come out for free
on disney club
and it got started off and went well
what's wrong with this because you know
the character gore
struggling across a desert
with his daughters you know his
dehydrated dying daughter in his arms
you know and there's one you know he
cradles or cradles her and he slumps
over and he's laying on the ground
cradling her then the next scene is him
cradling her grave and i thought that
was really remarkable cinema
and then i don't know what happened
it went off into
into
[ __ ] up land somebody
i don't know where they they were they
were taking cues from hr pup and stuff
or something
everybody must have been stoned
and it was
the goats and everything constantly
barking about stone that'd be like some
cocaine or something
i love that goat signal i think the
writers must have gone let's do this
screaming goats thing they're like that
thing was popping on youtube 10 years
ago and i'm like yeah let's do that
because that might be funny once no no
we're going
[Music]
into the last scene with gore right
and then it kind of become
really good again
you know
you know i really didn't like you know
when he took the the um the lightning
from zeus and empowered the kids
especially the little girl with the
teddy bear that was really i thought
really cool but and then when gore
passes through the portal
it gets back to
what i thought was cinema so
they should have just taken gore i mean
not gore they should have taken thor in
in jane completely out of the [ __ ]
movie and just had a movie about gore
now i hate ghour's character in this i
love you in in the first thor in
ragnarok sorry i loved god i thought it
was great in this movie the whole way
through i was just thinking i just wish
they'd punch him in his stupid little
face that's left
and just finished the guy off he's so
annoying but i hate but i am going to
watch thor again soon because as you're
right it's on disney plus and i've been
looking at it all week thinking i'm
going to watch it again but i haven't
quite got around to it with an open mind
because sometimes you know you're
looking forward to a film so much then
you walk through you're like oh you're
disappointed anything but then something
the second time around again you're like
no okay it's not as bad as i think
i suspect though it's as bad as i can
i've considered doing the same
because in the past week or so i i saw
something that said
maybe the film is better because on
bullet points it sounds great there are
very cinematic parts of it and
good cast etc etc all these things
it just the whole thing got dampened by
way too much humor and all the humor is
great it's just all of it at once
everything everywhere all at once did
not apply to thor love and thunder i can
tell you that
uh but
i i i've read that apparently of course
it's just a it's a way of looking at the
film
but korg is the unreliable narrator
maybe everything didn't happen exactly
as the movie
because he's just talking to the the
blue people uh at the beginning
throughout the middle and the end and
they really only spend the first
part of the first act on that planet
so they go back at a certain point is
this him talking about the future does
it who knows but
that doesn't satisfy me that anymore you
know it might make it oh there is a good
movie under this but
under under what why did we get that
you shouldn't have to think about it on
that level
this is maybe i'm just not thinking no
it's just not a good film it's not a
good one
yeah i but i did this with dr strange
too i didn't enjoy dr strange too first
time at the cinema um so i watched it
again when it came out disney plus
thinking open mind maybe it's better
than i think
it's not
it's just not a good film
um
there's bits of it i like
but generally as a pro
no good i tell you what marvel really
need to shake [ __ ] up because they're
going they're spiraling down for me and
excuse me i don't particularly like
she-hulk either
and i like it
yesterday today and they have not been
bringing anything all that new or
exciting they technically haven't
released
or announced anything that we didn't
know about yeah sure thunderbolts and
werewolf by midnight but that's been
online for the past
nine months not
two months in the last couple weeks it's
been there for a year almost yeah
oh that's crap
i tell you i've watched everything
you've watched except i'm not watching
thor again um but the one thing that did
jump out that i'd forgotten was coming
was lower decks and i got the first two
episode of lower decks
i love ludex
that's the funny animated one right yeah
yeah yeah
yeah the love letter to the next
generation which you never watched so
you wouldn't understand because you're
too young
um but yeah no it's just it just cracks
me up i love that show um
they seem to have toned back on the
humor a little bit and trying to take it
a little bit more seriously not much but
i know trekkies love or hate lower decks
and a lot of them hate it
um but for me i just i just love it
how from somebody that hasn't watched a
bunch of
star trek or
i very generally vaguely know about it
same thing with the orville orville i
feel like was supposed to be funny funny
for the first two seasons and then the
third season it dials back is that kind
of similar in a while
yeah they take it a bit more seriously
in the third series of orville 100 but
um
yeah
but anyway
that's what we watched i'm looking
forward to a couple of movies this week
but i'll tell you about that another
time so
a billion dollars
with a b
um
as we said that's what uh lord of the
rings spent and blah blah blah before
harris made me talk about what we were
watching this week harris it's my show
and then but so harris yeah what was
your first idea what was your first that
you what was the first thing that kept
your mind
so
was not it was not a project as you all
know i think amazon does struggle with
one thing in particular and that's
having their own space to make things so
i think they should spend 50 million
dollars on we're
square footage is a little uh tedious
here but um i think 500 000 square feet
would be a perfect sound stage form it
would allow them to do
james bond to stargate to expands
wheel of time to now they have hands
made tail they have all these different
things they they could do anything and
everything there and with that amount of
space they could do multiple projects
there at once um
did they spend should we spend 50
million obviously we'll talk about
budgets and stuff at the end and we'll
decide what we're going to do but it's
50 million enough or should we be
thinking about i mean because amazon
studios want to be which is why they
bought mgm
a proper big studio do they need two or
three same stages do they need you know
a backlog like warner brothers
they do i think they do
probably they did
they have a 325 000 square foot sound
stage their wheel of time so they have
one already this would add make it two
and i think making a little bit larger
of one would allow them a lot more
leeway
but they probably need a backlight as
well they probably need a few minutes
so i mean 50 million goes on about 50
million just buying land doesn't go a
great way but especially california so
we'll talk about but i mean you wouldn't
you do whatever marvel they're doing
you're building a film in georgia or
something
what city needs a little bit of
advertising and is willing to give us
some tax breaks that's that's how you
start that conversation isn't it you
know uh
north carolina has got a lot of
production space it used to be you
started out as carroll coast studios in
wilmington north carolina and he had all
sorts of things being made there a
little bit of dune was made there a
little bit of conan the barbarians made
there
i think x-files shot there a little bit
before it went to canada before the
american and canadian dollar flipped
uh the crow was made there i mean that's
where i got my start
in the business was just
farting around wilmington north carolina
and there's a lot of studio space in
north carolina
and you have the you know you have all
these different types of uh biomes you
can shoot in
sandy dunes
tallest mountains on the east coast
rolling plains and so you have a lot of
variety of outdoor shots i like
vancouver
which is all redwoods all the time
you know but um
i mean that'd be a good location georgia
is another one georgia has re the state
of georgia has really devoted a lot of
money to bringing in that kind of talent
north carolina did but then
politics got sad
sure
okay
right
so we we're definitely i'm putting that
on the list 50 million dollars or maybe
more we'll have think about that to
build uh
or buy
buy somewhere because there's probably a
lot of sound stages they could probably
buy and do maybe
okay so same stage studios
because at the moment
they tend to
fund projects and other people make them
that sense that tends to be the amazon
model
um
maybe they need to start making [ __ ]
themselves a bit more often so right 50
200 million for that i've written down
for now we'll talk about that so stormy
your first project what what what do you
want to make
i think this is probably one of the most
unrecognized
awesome book i mean it's got one ton of
tons of awards award-winning author red
mars
it's part of a trilogy red mars green
mars in blue mars it is about the
colonization
of mars
kim stanley robertson robertson is the
uh he's the
author and he treats scientists as the
heroes
you know
it's not the accountant it's not the
lawyer or anything like that
they're always evil no they're they're
always the people that cause the things
that do the thing that we all don't have
to run away from
but it is
it is just a remarkable series of books
three books uh
first book is how many 572 pages minus
acknowledgements
uh and that
the sets is going to be a little bit
pricey because
mars there's uh
there's a lot of scenes on earth
comparing the
the
um
sought after utopia that is mars in the
hellscape that is on earth in terms of
climate change overpopulation starvation
disease you know today
i just think what we should do is get
the muppets together and just remake
every tv show that's on tv now but with
the muppets so how to the dragon
muppets uh lord of the rings muppets
everything with the muppets
the boys with muppets
jesus christ
please invisible boys with muppets talk
about amazon and a whole new project for
them those two just come on yeah
together like things
on those two projects right
a behind the scenes thing where there's
just all the executives with all the
executives the thing is it might be a
bit too realistic a bit too close to the
bone
um but yeah
do i need to see miss piggy shouting
[ __ ] every third or four you can't say
that
miss
sorry
jesus christ youtuber i'm so sorry
that is the one word you cannot say
america not the uk well part of us we
might we might have some leeway
no it's the one word youtube really
don't like
well i was quoting
a show
i was quoting a character it's uttered
by carl you bane
over over and over and over and over and
over i can spell it out let me get
something no cnx juice is the only way
you can sit on my channel
see you next time
do i need to see
miss piggy
yeah
i always just got it right there goes
the monetization oh
sorry thank you
right oh well i'll edit that out
subtly he said celery really
salary
christ
right
red mars what's going on the list
so
are you my first choice right um this
might be a slight hint
but i can never do it i think right
yeah
i don't really care about anything on
your list
at all
um unless they bring stargate back now i
might have mentioned this on the channel
once or twice in the past
but i quite like stargate
um it's it's my favorite sci-fi show
it's even better than star trek i love
it i love it more than anything in the
world so i really want to see
um stargate come back and i'd looked
initially i'd like to see a new series
sg-1 style a team or something like that
getting out there in the universe big
grand proper sci-fi
um i would like to ask for 250 million
dollars of our budget to produce the
initial
20 episodes of a series over two seasons
um because i think you know you've got
you've got to sign up for two seats
you know go all the way
um and i think it would cost at least
250 million i think the first series i'd
quite like to see is maybe based on a
starship
um it's it's like and maybe a new bc305
a new
class of chip so a little star trekkiely
thing you know the stargate is real and
everybody knows about it and i'd like to
get out there and do a big sci-fi show
but it would be quite expensive
so that's my first pitch
sg-1 style get out there big sci-fi
uh stargate series
well i'm gonna ask you 250 million how
much are you asking for your project for
mars by the way did you want to make a
movie or a serious story oh in the oh
dude it's three books it's a 1500 pages
it'd have to be a series
but you know 10 episodes
i mean there's a lot of detail in kim
stanley robinson's books
and but you don't need
i mean it could be you know it's it's
kind of like think of it as the expanse
you know where the expan if you read the
expanse there's lots of detail
yeah with the belters and so forth but
it's
condensed down but it is still
the story is intact because i think you
could do that with uh
with um
red mars for
200 million
200 million for 10 episodes no two
seasons two seasons you want 20 episodes
200 million
okay we'll put it on the list 20
episodes so 20 hours of tv which is good
right okay
harris your first tv show
pitch hit us
we've already spent half the money so
yeah
should i
okay well okay so obviously i i'm still
working through sg one my first time
ever so i think
two stargate shows would be great i have
them budgeted at 300 million total i
think 110 million dollars per show with
an 80 million dollar marketing thing 40
million for each marketing right so two
stargate series for 300 million
yes
okay wow okay i think
and you know i'd love to give it a
couple more dollars but also filmmakers
restrained with with a decent budget but
restrained to a degree
sometimes has that like it just has that
magical quality because they had to find
a special way of doing something you
know that's what i'm hoping for there
so what sort of series are you thinking
about
i would i mean from somebody that has
not finished the whole thing i'm still
halfway through with one
i would say
have an sgc show a stargate command show
maybe
and
maybe don't necessarily focus as much on
the command have maybe a hammond type
person up there that is very prevalent
in the show but we get to follow
almost do it in an american horror story
style but not per season almost per
episode where you get to follow a
different sg team going out into these
different
you've got one command structure so the
one central thing but you actually see
the different teams going into different
missions week in weekend i just think
that's it formula for writers to follow
and it allows us to explore the whole
world of stargate and just
have fun with it i like the idea of
doing like a politically thriller type
of thing where um you've got you know
like the west wing or something like
that where it's more about the command
and the leadership and the
that side of things rather than the
actual better better
bringing up the idea of american horror
story and how that's shaped you know i
wonder if we need a stargate uh show
where at the end of every show
wolsey is killed in some dramatic
fashion you know like firing
fields
you bastards
fire ants whatever just as long as he
dies every in at the end of every
episode i think it would be worth it
look at stormy how i swore then but i
didn't say the c word see that it was
really easy i said fast
no no no you're not saying oh my god you
killed woolsey you bastards you're
allowed to say that you're not allowed
to say the word you said
that's a
i'll go back to throw in my other
because i have another stargate series
on my list all right so if i throw that
in while we're talking stargate then
i wanted to do and and the idea about
doing like an american horror sort of
show or like um
uh
i was thinking about
almost like um
the twilight zone or something where you
do a different story each week
um i want to do an ancient prequel
series
um i only want to do 10 episodes
i think one i think this is a one-hit
wonder i don't think we need to come
back to this loads and loads of times so
i'm only asking for 100 million dollars
to do this
um but i actually want to see
lots of different stories that would
that would be then linked to stuff we
saw in stargate but i want the very last
episode of that to be
some story going on
but in the background the destiny is
being constructed
and i don't
my first thought was just be really
subtle like you can just see the destiny
like through a window like in a shipyard
and the story's got nothing to do with
it
or you go fall out and you go
right we've we've detected this i'm
ruining this for you harris
in sgu they detected this signal that
they think was like a god signal and
that's why the destiny is like
um so you can do a whole thing about
that and that they build in multiple
destinies and you know whatever
so that would be the love
that would be the the the the prick with
them but i'd love to see lots of other
there's so many ancient storylines that
you could link together with different
things
but i only want to see one series so i'm
only asking for 100 million dollars to
produce my ancients prequel series which
i think is a freaking bargain
how much is the queen's funeral
not enough she deserves every penny i
just wonder what that was compared to
the budget she's i'm sure she's paying
for it it'll probably cost
i think the last state funeral we did in
equivalent terms cost 150 million
dollars and pounds to make it
much cheaper than i thought it would be
yeah state funerals are a big thing so a
lot of it is like government funded
anyway because it's like the military do
a lot of the work and stuff so
okay
um but yeah still enough to produce a
stargate tv show
yeah
all right so i've got that on the list
so what is your next
proposal stormy
uh my next one is
excuse me it is a novel
by frederick pohl an american sci-fi
writer uh he wrote this uh the first
novel was in 1977 called gateway
humanity finds
uh this asteroid
in this um elliptical orbit around the
sun where like here's the sun right here
here's the sun
earth goes this way they found an
asteroid doing this
so they launched a mission to this
asteroid which is in this peculiar orbit
and they find all of these alien
artifacts
and ships
now no one knows how the ships work
no one knows anything about the ships
and life is so piss-poor on earth
there's a lottery
to recruit people
to go on these ships and try different
experiments to see how they work and if
you
get something to work you get part of
the
the profits from whatever that is and
there's this one guy
he learns how to use the ship and come
back
and he makes tons and tons and tons of
money but the the the story is
where these ships come from and why did
the builders leave
and that's essentially a story and
there's uh probably four or five more
books after that
i think hitchy rendezvous was another
one
but yeah i thought that was a would be a
really good story because it's
it's a word
excuse me award-winning book
a great great story and you just don't
you just don't see that kind of story
very much and i thought it'd be very uh
i thought it would be a a respite from
all the the war kind of um
uh the conflict kind of uh stories we
see currently in sci-fi like a great
book
i haven't read it for years but god it
was a good book i don't think i've read
them
so you've read it i've read gateway
um i did go through a phase
um in my late teens early 20s and when
women wouldn't sleep with me that that
bad sort of period um where i read a lot
right um but it i haven't i don't having
kids and stuff i don't get to read much
anymore because it's like
that's that's dad
i'm a poo give me hello and at the same
time i get any time to go to myself but
but yeah no gateway's fantastic book i
love that um right i'm gateway's going
on listen right do you want to make a tv
series or do you want to make a movie oh
this is going to have to be a tv series
continuing to do the first two books
same form as before
um 200 million full uh budget 100
million per season 20 episodes total
okay
i need more than a billion right
okay
my next project is a movie and it's a
cheap one
and
fans of the channel um will know that
i've championed this before it's
something that mgm owned so they could
do reasonably cheap because we already
own the rights and again we're spending
amazon's money
um i want to make baseballs too
now i know
i know mel brooks
is a very very old man so he couldn't
appear in it but rick moranis actually
still looks like he's 15 years old so he
could do it
um
do you want me he's back in the acting
very little but he's back in there he's
back into it so we could see that and i
just want to see
i just want to see what they could do
with that now because i mean i want to
see a retro movie i want to see it like
you know do you think i i love take the
pissed films i think it's one of those
films that always fits
you know you could you can make any time
i don't we don't make like screwball
movies like that anymore and i just want
to see
i just think with disney and marvel
spending the money they are
and spending money on star wars it's
just right for a poke the fun take the
piss movie and space balls to
the search for money would be just
i want to see you damn it
um i love the title good that's great
that's what i want to say i want
spaceballs the sequel and they keep
talking about it they keep suggesting
they might do it and it doesn't quite
seem to happen but
i only want 100 million dollars to make
it these films generally don't cost a
great deal to make you don't have to
have any big stars in it
in fact i don't want any big stars in it
um i i just want
a funny movie mel brook style
um
you know and i want to see them go
ludicrous speed one more time
so i'm only asking for 100 million
freaking bargain if you ask me
harris your turn sir
so i'm going with the movie as well not
as cheap but i think with amazon buying
mgm and if they have their own sound
stage particularly
they need a new james bond film they
they need it out and they need to go
ahead and
solidify an idea and go forward with the
project um daniel craig was good and all
great at certain points
but the time's over and everyone's
looking forward to the future and until
they tell us who the new james bond is
everyone's just going to be yelling at
each other
so
i'd say bite the bullet and just get
henry cavill because he's he's james
freaking bond at that no no no no no
bloody americans no
no harris there's interesting too but
he's a little older no
he can't even just elbow either ill just
elbow 20 years ago
all day he is
putting on looks the man is bombed but
he's too old
um i can tell you from what i've been
told um but a couple of people i speak
to is it that that they want to go young
they want to go pre double 007.
thomas and tom holland is apparently oh
hell no
you just said henry cavill he's yeah
i love tom holland but he only has
gravitas when he's acting alongside
somebody else that has it as well
brings a presence to the screen that
only a james bond type actor can he's
going to be too busy doing highlander
and he will crush
highlanders
too
you know uh there before a hot second
quentin tarantino was wanting to do a
bond movie and i would really like to
see that right
you want to do a star trek movie as well
i really would love to see that
quentin tarantino could do with a bunch
of klingons
bunch of klingons i have a jewelry heist
oh my god i'd pay to see that
i wouldn't mind guy richie doing a bond
movie if they got him to actually
like calm down a little bit his last
couple of movies have been great he he
didn't do so good with a really big
budgets but you you know you'd like
get somebody in there to control him a
little bit i think um he could do a good
movie
from uncle
you what sorry have you seen the man
from uncle yeah that's okay
but henry cavill could be buying just
from there
oh he can't be
no he can't be harris
he's too big
he also can't be sherlock holmes he's
also terrible enough
i quite like the enola homes movies but
henry cavill sticks out like a massive
sore thumb it's like like they got my
thumb and they smash it with a hammer
and they go look he's sherlock holmes in
the new movie
it's absolutely crap
he's he's got very he's brilliant
superman all right and he's and he he
was actually brilliant in the villain in
that mission impossible movie he was
great yeah
and even though that movie then ruined
justice league
because he had his mistake
i think i think
out of all this i got another idea you
know we could have in the vein of the
expendables we could have something this
is a quentin tarantino project keep that
in mind called the dishonorables where
you have a bunch of klingon gangsters
running around ripping people off
and then their arms off
there's something there though
and killed him with his own arm
goblin
right okay i will put james bond on how
much money do you want to spend on this
james bond movie because i'm telling you
what the last one cost 200 million quid
50 million and do 150 million for the
actual budget hundred million for
marketing
okay 250 million bond a project they're
100 doing anyway which was i'm not sure
where we were quite going with this idea
we're supposed to be stuff they weren't
going to do anyway but they're 100 doing
bond anyway
but we'll throw it in the pot
and see where we come out stormy
next neolis my friend
next on my list is uh there is a
character
from a series of children's books back
in the
previous century
uh called tom swift it was it was uh
geared for boys
but there was lots of
actual science
in the ms like nancy drew and tom and
the hardy boys there's lots of logic and
puzzle solving that was in through the
books but this is
here here's like a cover tom swift and
the sonic boom trap
uh tom swift in the polar ray dinosphere
and there's a whole series i mean god
there's tons of these i've got a
some of these i saved because they're
just mint condition but i'd like to get
like an animated show for kids
you know kind of done on the cheap you
know um
you know 20 episodes
maybe i don't know 100 million
altogether you know like the you know no
name voice actors and so forth tom swift
active planetoid
and it's
with especially with america and how
allergic we are to science these days i
thought something like this especially
entertaining kids show
tom swift from the sub ocean geotron
i think it's kind of you know think
about it it's like um
one episode of reading rainbow to take
one book but it's just you know it
teaches the science it's entertaining
the kids and not just boys you know it's
just you know it could be tom swift and
in his sister or whatever and geforce
but i think at least like in you know
for my production i'd like to do
something that's educational for kids
and animated and fun
animated like you know lower decks or
uh
rick and morty or whatever it doesn't
have to be a style it has to be good and
educational and entertaining
cool i love that idea right i'm gonna
put a star next to that one i like it
okay my next
option um was again something that mgm
owns
um it's something that i'm absolutely
certain amazon are going to do a lot of
because they're going to take all the
stuff they own and remake it
um logan's run
i went through a list of all the mgm
movies that they've got that they could
remake and modernize and i think
a film that would deserve a
modernization
and that would be still relevant today
because you know you think about the
relationship between technology and
mankind and
our limited resources moving forward to
the future and you know um
freedom and our
supposed lack of it nowadays
i just think it's a movie that could
have late a lot of layers to it um i
want to see
somebody like um i can't remember her
name there oh chip is it jenny hackathon
something like that the very pretty lady
anyway that run around and very little
for most of the movie
um and we need to resurrect peter you
snuff because actually to be fair
everything that peace unoff did was
amazing and he's in that as well
um so we need to sort of like cgi him so
it might be quite expensive but no
logan's run is a movie that i just think
is one of those films that is primed to
get a modernization a modern remake um
so yeah i i i even don't think it would
be a massively expensive movie to
produce i think 150 million dollars
would make the film because a lot of the
film is actually i mean there's a lot of
sets and stuff but a lot of it is
character driven so there's not massive
cgi we're talking about even potentially
we could even probably squeeze it out
for 100 million if we're really really
tight i mean they did batgirl line
across 80 million
i reckon we could do cheaper than that
so
logan's run
great movie absolutely loved it we own
the rights to it let's make it again
damn it
um
100 million 150 million interesting
we could get a couple of name backers
this
mean because there's limited i mean if
you're doing like you know some sort of
faithful remake of it
i mean you've got these you know small
contained forests or environments and
you got some you know the deck of the
ship
essentially and so it is character so i
think you could do it for 100 million i
mean there's
you know really good looking stuff on
netflix that had a you know that's
sci-fi and out in space it had a budget
of 50. it was really really good
there we go
i feel that's that's all this this this
that one could be in the bucket so i i
like the response harris just out of
question you've never seen it have you
logan's run yeah
no i haven't but i know
let me children anyway never mind um go
watch it it's from the 60s um
i've been told a million times i really
do need to watch
um
sorry bob's just put a comment on i'm
going i'm going to add that
let's do a reboot the classic original i
love that film
with a truck jason i'd love that film
electric by green toyota by tesla
so you have to just keep driving to the
battery right now right yeah it would be
very short
short film and my electric car can drive
for about two hours and then it dies
anyway
can can the tesla be a cyber truck oh my
god because that's kind of you know i'll
be in it it's gotta be and then
something will bounce off the
instructable windows and i'll just
shutter
love it
sold
down there
and he must come and bring an extra
couple hundred million you know yeah you
shoot it all on location on on on
pacific coastline
we don't have to put any money into this
just just aim elon musk
cool a couple of tesla's done
harris you've got another go
all right so this one i'm going to bring
it back
i got some more sci-fi on that on our
next round but i think keeping it
grounded for the whole mgm slash amazon
studios nowadays now that they have mgm
and now that there's inevitably going to
be another creed movie i know creep 3's
in the works and all that i think that
bringing the rocky and
i i think with creed having movies and
sly stallone already kind of saying yeah
i'm out of the movies i'm not going to
be involved with any more of the creed
but he's also taking his first
television role with
that uh uh
tulsa king i believe is what it's called
and um
he's playing a a gangster that's from
new york going in and taking over tulsa
and kind of making it a whole game land
of his own kind of deal so with him
being willing and able to take a tv role
and he just sold and not he didn't do it
himself but he just did samaritan with
amazon crying
yeah i bring him fly back
and put him in a kind of cobra kai style
version for boxing uh and have him be
running
jim and
maybe going to a couple different gyms
as a liaison kind of deal but yeah i
think there's easily a story around
there i don't know
just
reboot you want to do it with sly
yes i think he would need to come back
and he would be the selling point for
the show
he loves boxing he loves rocky i mean
he's done a couple of tv show he did a
reality tv series a couple years ago
didn't he about boxing and getting the
next big thing and stuff so um
he didn't he wasn't in it a great deal
he just sort of like a good expanded bid
at the end something but but okay oh so
you don't want to do a rocky reboot you
want to do a rocky tv series oh yes how
much money do you want to spend on this
pile of crap i mean how much money do
you want to spend on this amazing
project that you've thought of
150 million 150 million dollars for the
show you got to get sly and then 50
million for marketing
oh dear god okay
marketing has a bigger price tag and all
this stuff are you a millennial harris
just another question
or which other millennial were you born
i i was born
february of 99 so i'm like right between
millennial and the gen x or i'm going to
say you're a millennial which explains a
great deal with the last five minutes of
our lives okay
i'm sorry
no
rocky tv series let's do that
sorry happens i
i do like cobra kai i've just started
watching the new series i [ __ ] love
coca-cola but anyway right so stormy
you're
got one more
well i've got i've got two more the next
one is a reboot i was also a big fan
of the series of books by terry brooks
sword of shannara
back in the late 70s and whatever sci-fi
channel did to it was indescribably
painful oh
i mean
oh
it was bad
it was just atrocious it it
it was a crime against humanity what
they did to this wonderful book and it
was just
you know people [ __ ]
about uh the rings of power
holy crap they didn't they they need to
take a shot at that i mean they really
because it was it was horrible i think
you know for out of my billion dollars
i'd like to take a quarter million
dollars and
you know do two seasons of sort of
shinara just the book sword is not the
whole series
not the whole just that book with the
with the druid allen on
and the sword and we start you know you
start out at shady veil
yeah
and work your way through
oh it god yeah that was such a
the the hell the author
deserves better oh yeah
did you say you want 250 million dollars
for this bar
yes okay right
that's that's the high fantasy we need
right there that's the whole thing yeah
that's gotta be 20 now
20 hours
20 hours of tv for that yeah two seasons
again yeah that first book is 730
pages-ish no it's just yeah it's yeah
yeah
but like you said though the sci-fi what
sci-fi channel did that oh god they even
had men who've been at jon reece davies
and austin butler which
alanon high king of the elves and and
shea himself were that he wasn't no he
wasn't shay he was playing will honestly
right yeah
but
it could have been
i could go on about that yeah i mean we
could spend an hour here bitching about
how
how badly the that was dropped i mean
i would drop the series right up next i
would rather put my testicles in advice
and twist until i heard a popping sound
then watch that again oh
it was that bad
yeah it was really bad
and then fought fault on the wound
so anyway i'd like to take a portion of
my money and remake that and do it right
i mean it was yeah i was so excited when
that show came out
i should have known better
my last i this is my last throw in the
dice
thomas um
wrote a book uh called gravity rainbow
back in 1973.
this book
won awards at the time and it was it's
considered to be one of the
um top 100 sci-fi novels of all time and
it's never been made into a tv series or
a movie or anything
partly because
some of the themes of this are a bit
out there all right
it's actually based just after world war
ii and the general very vague plot is
that there's a bunch of v2s
and they were being sent um an an attack
in london and there was some
box on it called the black device
and the whole thing is then trying to
figure out what what what it was and
what happened
there's some quite psychosocial elements
to this that the actual the whole the
book
starts
with the main character going out and
investigating this this other character
wherever he had
sex
then a v2 hit the same location a couple
of days later and that's how the book
starts
right and then but oh it goes on
there's there's a massive drug addiction
in this book
um like i say so there's the beautiful
thing about it was this is the thing
this is why it might be a little bit
difficult to make or we might need a
very big sound stage isn't this the plot
to eastenders
yes
yes it is um there's as many characters
there's 400 characters in this book this
is the 400 character one
which is why it might make it difficult
euphoria and game of thrones yeah yeah
yeah um so um it might be a bit
difficult to follow um
if he wrote the book in lots of
different styles to represent the
different perspectives and things of the
different people um during the the story
and so that might be a little bit
difficult to represent in the movie as
well
um i think for this i would want a
300 million dollars to make
40 hours of tv because they were
actually the book was split into four
sections
um
it wouldn't be massive cgi costs it's
more
set around
post war britain and germany
but there are some white hardcore sci-fi
elements to it as well
um
but yeah it's it was a book that blew my
freaking minds when i was a kid and i
read it and particularly because i have
to google one of google back then but i
had to like get a dictionary and find
out what a lot of the words meant
particularly when it's not about the
psychosexual elements i was only like
15. well i'm not that girl doesn't let
me touch you yet i don't understand that
um but it's not
it it's a way out there it's way way out
there
but oh my god nobody'd watch it
except me
but i mean um oh it'd be amazing
and this is the sort of thing though to
be fair that hbo max should do
because
in places but we like that
so um yeah
gravity rainbow
look it actually became a series of
books i believe but i only have a red
gravity rainbow
but that's my that's my last
throw of the dice
tv show anyway yeah
it would have to become a stripped-down
version of that anyway you couldn't you
couldn't make it with all the characters
he put in he'd never be able to follow
them
different perspectives and stuff could
you almost tackle it like a sandman in a
way how they don't necessarily have
dream that's the pivotal guy all the
time but
play some where he's necessary
yeah you'd have to definitely do an
adaptation of this in a different way
but i would love to see
if it filmed in different styles and
different things to go through because
you get somebody really creative with
this they could do all sorts with it the
the the source material is absolutely
rich mental but rich
um and yeah i think there's some amazing
things you could do with it
absolutely nice
uh but harry's gone you've got you've
got another throw the dice oh yeah well
technically i've got two i got another
another star gate but i also that one
i haven't watched enough stargate yet i
don't know where a second series would
be if my heart had anything to say i'd
say just give me a tilt series just
strictly just anything all things teal
but if i'm i'm being realistic my final
thing is going to be
i think
with properties that they already have
is i'm not suggesting more rocky or
creed don't worry but i think they
should bring back expanse
and i think they should do a go film
route with it instead
to
almost get a larger audience
to go back and watch the expanse on
amazon itself because i i think they
could do a great film on i think they
have two or three books left that they
haven't recovered
three okay
and
give us a movie doesn't need to be the
same cast could be the same cast i'm not
i haven't read uh i think it's the
leviathan series so i know they skip in
the future and
it's 30-year gap between book six and
seven yeah that could be the same cast
with a little bit of makeup a little bit
they've all got drugs that make them
oh
they don't age
so that's fine
i think we need a tilt cooking show
you know don't you think so
you know three eggs
and
cooking with two nights for me one bite
for junior you know just yeah
he hasn't got junior anymore oh no sorry
that's a spoiler
what
whoa
i get to anticipate and come up with
theories in my head about how that
happens i'm not i'm not angry don't
worry
i i might have some news about the
expanse but i'm not going to tell you
i have heard something very interesting
from somebody that actually i've heard a
couple of rumors about the expanse
recently one was that they want to do a
um
spin-off series
um which was something to roll from
season six
there's a lot of threads from season six
that um
they would they wanted to
tell you a little bit of the rumor that
i've heard apparently the plan was
always to do a spin-off series
and that's why certain things from
series six happen because they're
setting that up and they stand out they
stand out a bit and they don't get
resolved
and that's why they happened it's uh is
it the iconia oh i forgot the name there
damn it
it's the people that turn that go for
mars anyway and go into them it's it
might be based around that
but that is the plan but it gets a bit
more complicated than that because the
production company that actually owns
the show
don't want amazon to do it and
apparently the reason one of the reasons
why they've got a hiatus is they're
trying to run the contract down but i'm
not saying any more than that you're
going to have to wait for the video next
week
thank you john
the laconians
i'm suggesting expanse from a fan of the
expanse i also not necessarily the two
weakest seasons by far five and six
after amazon got their foothold on it
yeah so that might not be the worst idea
at the same time yeah i think that the
moment is it's gonna be an expansion of
season six but the the rumor i've heard
as well is that it'll be a much smaller
past a much more focused story
and the whole idea is to bridge to
potentially maybe do season seven in in
five or six years
uh but we'll see or apparently hbo max
is very interested in taking
the expansion
that's the big rumor
because they can't happen
but if hbo max take it they want at
least something that won at least five
seasons
so there will be two seasons in between
i've got amazing [ __ ] video now i've
done all my notes for it it'll be two
seasons there's a bridget and then
they'll go into book seven is what hbo
would like to do but amazon owned the
knights so they have to wait but anyway
ruined that for anybody that watches
that video fine whatever you can clip it
right
yeah i'll clip it
and there's a bit more to it than that
but this guy talks he's like saying
told me a few little details it's really
interesting so anyway so stormy your
last
option before we decide what we're
actually going to spend money on the the
the last pitch the last thing i want to
do is
a really big sci-fi movie
and i got two ideas i'm not sure which
would be the strongest
they're they're both
award-winning great novels one is
rendezvous with rama
i rendezvous rama is a novel by
authority clark
the um there's this huge object that
comes into the soul yes never seen
before
and uh humanity launches a mission to it
as it rides through the uh solar system
they have to learn as much about the uh
the ship called rama before it exits the
solar system
that's so that's one
the other one is ring world by larry
niven
now this is real there's several ring
wing world books and technology but i'd
like to focus just on
the original the the first book by the
larry again
you know it's another kind of um
like running with rama was you know he
was discovering um
an alien artifact huge alien artifact
same kind of theme with uh
ring world humanity finds this world
that is literally a ring around the sun
okay and uh
it's an exploration of the culture and
the people that built it
so i don't know which one what do you
guys which one do you do ring world or
rendezvous with wrong
you have to do ring world because i
don't know if you're
[Music]
i don't know if you've heard of it but
they're making a rendezvous with rama
movie
oh they're already well there well it's
gotta be directing it
right i i don't think it's happening
anymore it's not a word
um this is one of those things that was
sort of announced uh
2019.
december 15th 21 is what hollywood
referred to
okay the last time i heard was it was up
in there
there's a lot of projects that seem to
be stuck in development hell at the
moment though because people don't want
to spend any money but yeah i know that
was definitely one that was being looked
at to make
didn't even villanue was supposed to
direct it after dune part two
yep
well fingers crossed well they've just
put june back again though
production's not starting on june until
next year and they're talking about 2025
until we're going to see it 2026. so
they've just put june back again
um so let's see what happens but but
yeah um
ringworld there's also rumors that
ringworld's happening
but i think fox own it
did you
so those you picked two there that might
actually happen stormy
oh well
well that's that's good because you've
picked two great projects that hopefully
are actually going to happen
i'd be amazing would it be if we
actually pick some stuff off this list
that actually then gets made
but right okay so
now we have to actually go through this
and figure out what we actually want to
make
do we think that if this is our 100
million you know billion dollars did we
do we want to make stand stage do you
want to spend 50 million quid
and actually have our own sound stage
i'd say it was it'd be necessary but
i'm open to uh
we're democracy here
i i think 50 million is a good
investment in this new
um thing and again we're trying to spend
a billion dollars better than amazon
have spent it
for me
we need a studio damn it we need
production
you know yeah
and we should call it ricksome studios
that's my name so uh
excellent 50 million dollars can you put
it in for that yeah
right okay so
i throw the projects out i'm going to
throw the projects out at you so we got
red mars stargate sg1
and another stargate series potentially
two
uh 19 uh gateway series spaceball
sequel no brain all right um
james bond wrestling made anyway so
let's scratch james bond off it's
definitely getting made 100 right so
they're gonna do that anyway
um the tom swift series anime logan's
run um a rocky tv series
it would make them money and it would do
well but i know y'all don't want to see
it
i don't watch it
cobra k i can't even speak cobra kai
vein i haven't even watched cobra kai
yet but i it's on my list it's on my
list i know kobakai is amazing
um
a reboot of the
sword of chana we've got
expanse
whether we want to do the movies or the
thing i mean
amazon's still up in the air about that
um rendezvous with rama and ringworld
adaptations possibly too we're
scratching them off because they're
actually possibly getting made anyway if
you're getting made scratches off the
list let's scratch my list right so
we got to have stargate right i mean i
think everybody in the
i think we're a stargate channel whether
we like it or not
sorry
cooking with teal i'm all about it king
of teal so
we've got a stargate series
first what are we going to do like the
big sci-fi grand
series first
do you think
i reckon it'll cost about 10 million
dollars an episode
if you're gonna do it right
star trek costs about eleven million
dollars an episode let's at least do it
right
okay so we'll put
we'll put i think put 200 million to one
side for two seasons
20 hours
of tv
are we happy with this
don't just say yes because it's my
channel and i cannot kick you off before
you say something i don't like
nah yeah
i think you know you know i won't kick
you off you know i'm scared of both of
them so okay we're good so i think we
pick a movie should we pick a movie
so we out of movies we've got space
balls
uh logan's run
uh
maybe the one of the expanse moves
i like the
logan's spaceballs you say
so if i write spaceballs now
come on spaceballs how much do you want
to sell me well okay logan's run
logan's run spell s-b-a-s-c-e
what do you think you stole harris
you've never seen logan's run so is this
something you are interested it's
basically you lifted 30 and then they
vaporize you
because
of like limited resources so everyone
lives in like a utopia until you'd reach
30. so then logan reaches 30 and he goes
[ __ ] that i'm out of here and he legs it
with jenny hager i keeps calling jenny
hackathon i'm not sure that's a name but
anyway a 50.
honestly
and then they meet him pereira in the in
the desert so it's a good film
they can be filmed on tattooing
it could be everything else's so uh
i reckon we could do that for 100
million
honestly we're doing quite well here
because so far all we've spent is 400
million we're doing all right
god
we've got a sound stage in studio to do
that includes the sound stage too yeah
yeah your massive project
do we want to do
a second stargate series just before we
move on
i'd love to see the ancients or
i i wouldn't mind seeing a um
a jaffa series i wouldn't have seen a
jaffa series
park style
so a second series like something like
an ancient series or something what's
the vote what's the vote
people i like the stargate command one
you know
the veins of you know a west wing
yeah
you know
a lot of the ones between with the the
president vice president like
with the the corrupt
senator
those were really entertaining it was
just the intrigue and how many people
was trying to shaft the program and so
forth because you know the
the ioa and all the rest of them there's
a lot more backstory there and we only
see the brunt of it as you know with the
characters
like but what other kind of
backstabbing was going on i mean
something as powerful as the stargate
you know there was i mean you know with
the nid and all that yeah
so there's got to be a lot of really
evil crap going on in the background
first in idea it was not the first night
episode where the episode where mayborne
really is
broken out and it has to go help o'neill
and all that and that that's great just
the an id and the implications they have
there alone yeah yeah
i'll tell you what we'll do the ancients
so show if we've got some money left
over at the end of the pot so there you
go we'll have a look i love the idea
mini
series
yeah i think i think that's the way to
go but okay so we've got the tom swift
animated series um i actually think
that's a lovely idea and i think
we should do that
yeah that you know of all the ones i
picked as us that would be my number one
to do and it's the cheapest
and you gotta think about the children
and i think i think hundred million is
loads and money to spend on that yeah
maybe we could do more seasons
that could get you four or five honestly
i don't think we put 50 million
okay
two seasons 20 hours 50 million
20 hours of children's programming
that's really cheap
yeah
yeah i think it's doable
um and we're picking numbers out of
things so we still got red mars
which is a brilliant idea i love the
swords of shannada
done properly
and that would be expensive done
properly
how much do we have left in the budget
let's have a look so we have
fifty one hundred
three hundred four we've only actually
only spent four hundred million dollars
so far is that really time swift
that includes tom swift but i've only
put that at 50 million which now i'm
thinking might be a bit cheap
but we've still got 600 million dollars
to spend
well i like the red mars idea because if
amazon
keeps expands ip i guess in their
wheelhouse i don't know if that
they obviously don't correlate at all
but if it is strictly about the
colonization of mars you could correlate
those worlds and have them almost
expand together
into the expanse um
you've had a couple of seasons series as
well that's a bit like that and it is
topical again isn't it because i'm with
elon musk
i mean red mars is mostly uh it's a uh
character story
you know it's not really i mean yeah
it's in a sci-fi universe then there's
space shots and most of it does take
care take place on mars but mostly it's
a people story you know so those tend to
be
cheaper than just high sci-fi yeah yeah
space
have a volume or something compared to
oh yeah
we have 400 million left right and we've
only got a couple of projects do you
reckon we could get
baseball's movie
the thoughts of china
and
um
another sg series out of 400 million
as much as i'd love to put another sg
series on there would we want to save
just
30 50 million dollars to put on other
are we not thinking about that at all
like putting extra money on current
existing projects because like story
mentioned wheel of time
a couple extra dollars okay nature show
probably that could use a couple extra
dollars they just got the hands made
tail from mgm
so
they could do a movie out of that uh
i don't know that's just spitballing at
the very end
but uh
well i i think you know at least from my
batch the sword of shannara and the mars
trilogy are going to be the priciest
ones
and probably gateways i mean just pick
you know one of those
big
forgotten about gateway i i think
gateway
such a great book
it was a great book maybe we should just
be a movie
i i think gateway could be a movie
i think that would work
you know i'd love to have to strip it
down a fair bit but i think that could
work as a movie i mean the book is what
180 200 pages
most of it is again character based and
very few uh sets
so maybe 100
i guess you could you know if it was a
shot like an independent film maybe a
hundred million dollars you could easily
squeeze gateway in there
yeah i i've put 150 million i want to
see a big star in that
i think it's such a character-driven
thing i think you've got to have a big
name in it
and i was thinking
um oh i don't know his name is another
guy from um
better call saul
yeah bob
i love that guy i mean i i could when i
thought about this the first name i
thought of as the leading guy
that was who i thought of
nobody
he's just i don't know it's just i love
him in that film he did not longer where
he plays like the spy and i forgot what
his damn called
nobody sorry you said it twice didn't
you
nobody i hope that would sequel i love
that film i thought it was great and
he's brilliant in it
um so yeah i could see that
it's chess tohilsky so i hope they bring
that in with john wick at a certain
point
yeah i'm sure they might do actually
but yeah i'm going to say gateway and
i'm going to give us 150 million dollars
for it um i think
we're gonna think
and then
i think the short swords of chana
that's that's
i i think we're all too privy to it not
too
yeah it's too
because it was
done so badly
even my kids wouldn't watch it
and we actually have 250 million dollars
left to do it
and so i would say that's an easy good
20 episodes
yeah
so i mean we've created
instead of 50 hours television of rings
of power we've created 20 40
60
80 hours of television and a movie
and two movies
out of that instead and i think they're
reasonably reasonable
budgets
yeah honestly they're
big budgets
yeah they were all big budget movies
things oh oh sorry
spaceballs so um we've gone over budget
by 100 million dollars
for a second um but yeah so we are going
to make we're going to build a sound
stage for 50 million quid that we're
going to film space balls on and then
we're going to do stargate for 200
million dollars um immediately after we
filmed spaceballs and then we'll do
logan's run which we can probably use a
lot of the spaceball sets which will
even save us some money
and then we're going to do the tom swift
animated bit and we'll use some of the
actors from space balls to do some of
the voices for it um red mars again
space ball set so again saving money um
gateway
space water and the swords of shinar
the wheel of time lord of the rings
we'll use the director from space balls
to do it
[Laughter]
so
again
saving money saving money so say we've
done well there um costs and mata just
said if we included costs for the cast
we've
put in 200 million dollars
we can we can afford some actors we'll
give them some percentages or something
at that point yeah yeah exactly find
somewhere on the back end it goes
straight and then don't tell him it's
going to straighten rhymes and prime
yeah you get 20 percent at the back end
charlotte i'm sorry
yeah turning something back in oh yeah
anyway
gentlemen we have saved amazon
i think so
how did we do that congratulations
we i mean not they didn't necessarily
needed saving but we've done it anyway
um
you got me
what'd you say sir i said sorry
shelly made a good point and forgot the
muppets
no no we're going to do that as well
but we're just going to do that as well
as everything else but there is no
there is no money on that we will just
we will do that from love
and we will make everything every
project we're doing we'll do a muppets
version
of every single one um i want to see a
muppet's version of gateway and we've
already kind of seen a muppets version
of gate of stargate actually
so kind of
uh in the 200th episode they weren't
muppets really really they were more
like um
world police but yeah they're still
puppets
anyway muppets in space stargate style
boy
but thank you guys and
i tell you what winter is coming it's
dark here
amazing we're finished and it's dark
it's crazy it's not dark there it's 50
degrees yesterday that's why my i need
new lighting so i'm on a look creepy
mind at the moment
but anyway
my next my next um money from amazon i'm
buying new lighting my wife starts a new
job next week so i get the office space
to myself so i can actually set up like
a little studio and have proper lights
and not have to keep putting up and take
it down put it particularly there so um
i could actually set it up properly oh
it's the dream it's the dream
yeah i can't wait so
nice thank you so much for joining me
again this sunday it's been an absolute
dream as always other than harris coming
up with his rocky idea that we
immediately
obviously i want to say like a
tumbleweed
amazon's going to give me a call don't
worry i'm i'm waiting for it man you
should present
stallone's not going to present all of
it you should present but it does mean
you have to get punched in the face
occasionally
yep there you go let me say that what
tyson said about boxing says all the
strategy and all the training whatever
go straight out of the window as soon as
i punch you in the face
oh it's quite like that because all the
all the dancing and all the strategy and
all of them
punch you in the face so
smacks you
yeah exactly
anyway right so
guys thank you again so much say bye
thanks for having me
thank you it was fantastic
well stormy it is nice to see you
looking
a bit healthier and a little less snotty
so
those last oh it sucked it sucked you
sound great as well
thank you
eddie have you plugged it in yet
there he is he's got it
sounds much better
i have covered for three days
covered for 30 days a loser i i did it
properly
guys
thank you so much see you next time
whether you like it or not we will be
like or not
bye everybody
[Music]
you